[Music]
in
nazi news oh great my favorite
it is kind of cool news though he has to
say something why
not it's my favorite you gotta say
something it's pretty fascinating is
hitler still alive it's pretty
fascinating that they're still like nazi
news right oh yeah a 101 year old former
nazi guard was just sentenced to five
years in prison for aiding in more than
3 500 murders during the holidays did he
laugh
he's like i'm 101 you know five years
really
five
five years that's all you get for doing
all that a life sentence for him
the specific number is actually uh he
has just been convicted of aiding in
three thousand five hundred and eighteen
murders while he was a nazi camp guard
eating in three thousand murders for and
he gets five years ago
is it in germany like they found him in
germany i found him on a carnival crew
a princess scream he was singing my way
we are going live
hi man
i have it my
this
oh man so yeah uh
he was convicted on tuesday for aiding
and abetting the murders of more than 3
500 people while serving it as a guard
uh at a nazi concentration camp during
the holocaust and uh pretty much the uh
in germany yes it was in germany they
found the man guilty of
3518 counts
of accessory to murder over killings
that took place between january 1942 to
february 1945.
the man denied working as a
sh shoot stuff
should stop i got this point
this is my people shoot shoot stuff
there you go
an
ss guard in the
[Laughter]
just north of berlin per the german
newspaper uh the court did not name the
man due to germany's privacy laws but
several local outlets identified the man
as joseph
s
yes oh sss i really the really narrow
yeah that'll be good
the man claimed that he worked as a farm
laborer in northeastern germany during
world war ii
but the quote
you got him there
but the court said the prosecution had
proven that he was the guard in question
that's a picture of him like
grave style
says joseph s
he goes what that is not me
ironically uh the prosecution had
presented the court with photos
documents and ss personnel records
matching his personal details i think
he's today they're they're taking
pictures in the camp like these aren't
gonna bite us in the ass at any time in
the future
he's doing he's doing my way in the camp
on video
and they matched it
they matched it
that he had led prisoners to gas
chambers or to their executions but
didn't prove whether or not he took part
in the act of killing them well that's
his button pushing right yeah yeah he's
just doing his job right yeah
during the case a historian detailed the
prisoners dismal conditions at sakshin
saxon housing session
and 16 joint plaintiffs including 10
holocaust survivors were also involved
in the proceedings so like this guy for
real pharaoh did get caught i like the
fact that you said uh that he's just
kind of the button pusher like how what
does that mean to you
so i don't know i feel like if you're
a shot caller right they deserve like
full-on war crime penalties but then
sometimes if you're like like let's say
you're drafted on their side right like
i have a little bit of empathy because
i'm like they're just
a german
taken over by some crazy dictator and
then
they they don't want to get killed right
they still want to be like a breadwinner
for their family so i think like like uh
morality-wise i'm like [ __ ] i don't know
man because like if he's just like well
i guess i'm gonna be a guard for these
people and i'm following what my
president or my leader wants to do he's
doing what he thinks is right yeah he's
doing what he's thinking he's not
masterminding the whole
that's the banality of evil though right
that's the that's the whole thing they
talk about during the holocaust and
during world war ii is that you have all
these pictures and videos from germany
and all the you know access controlled
like uh countries and everyone's just
like kind of going about their day
because that's their reality but if you
i mean if you still take a step back you
have to be like oh well still [ __ ]
evil yeah still [ __ ] evil you're
participating in this you know greater
evil of things so that's the that's the
back and forth i mean it's easier for us
to 100 because
well it's the same argument we're having
right now with like um a lot of soldiers
that are fighting for russia right
they're just like yeah a lot of these
guys don't even know that there's a war
going on they're just like they just got
sent there and they're just like oh [ __ ]
we're shooting shooting actual bullets
of people they thought it was a military
action yeah they're like i joined
because i'm patriotic and then later on
they're like oh are shooting ukrainians
what the [ __ ] imagine you're a russian
soldier but you're working on the east
the eastern border and you're just like
i don't know what everyone's talking
about we're not doing [ __ ] over here
this is asia right yeah it's like it's a
big country got a [ __ ] huge border
wheat on this side yeah it's like
there's a beach i don't know
[Laughter]
you're so sorry i did see uh i think i
forgot what it was called it's on hbo
there was a recent movie that came out
about a a fighter or a boxer in the
concentration camps anybody know what
i'm talking about
it's not hbo there's so much um
but it paints a it's a movie and it's
mainly black and white or some [ __ ] like
that but it paints uh the story like a
jewish boxer yeah so it was a jewish
dude who was in a concentration camp and
then one of like the ss guards or
whatever i don't know what the proper
term is but it's just like you like i
saw you uh punch this one dude and
that's kind of how the movie starts he's
like come come do this thing and then he
brings him in he like treats him all
good and stuff but then he has him fight
other jews in boxing rings and i'm
talking to the death type [ __ ] right
so then there's um but he apparently was
really really good so after the war was
over he again uh he tries to box in
america but then uh spoiler he gets
outed as uh the boxer who was notorious
in the jewish camps for fighting other
jews and he's jewish himself exactly so
he's a backstabber exactly but the the
comp the complexity is that same thing
right you're in a concentration camp you
don't really have a lot of choices and
then you're presented with this option
in one sense and he and even during that
it shows a conflict where it's not like
he wants to fight to the death but when
you get put into a ring and you have to
fight for the death it's either you
fight for the death or you die because
the other guy's gonna do it i'll kill
you you should have done the right thing
and what's the right thing not to not to
kill anybody i think you're right thank
you which which
it's hard to say these kinds of things
not at all trying to paint the picture
like this guy was a button pusher and
like he had no
moral wrongdoing and participated out
for the [ __ ] idiots that think that
you're justifying it it's the best well
yes yes
i mean if you're 101 years old and these
crimes that you're being prosecuted for
were 70 or 60 years how what is that
yeah what took him so [ __ ] long 7 84
70 to yeah 70 years plus ago and now
you're like 101 and now you get five
years of jail time like where are you
guys how are you are you laughing at it
imagine you felt like you got away with
everything
and then at 101 they tell you you're
going to jail you're like you did
because 101 i was like you got to live
out most of your life as a free person
you're not free it was 101 bro you need
people to wipe your ass for you so you
might as well be in jail that's
literally where you go in a retirement
home you're in jail but it's like does
he even know what's going on at this
point like maybe he's just like mentally
like calls himself out at 101 he's like
hey by the way i was aiding into bedding
can somebody put me in this institution
hey i just duked myself could somebody
clean it up please
[ __ ] sakes
a picture of them right
uh they tried to keep his identity
so literally there's no picture i'm
talking like for privacy laws in germany
this is all we get
[Laughter]
i know right horses he's 101 years old
you just [ __ ] his pants right now that's
why he's embarrassed he put it covered
his face
this is my way that's crazy this is my
way
isn't that crazy look at old people and
they all look innocent but then when you
think about it they're involved done
shitty [ __ ] well some old people look
evil
like who
i don't know we could go out on the
street we can go find someone
[ __ ]
oh my god robert de niro kind of looks
like he could be like yeah grumpy grumpy
older or not no maybe he's cause he's
always held these like mafia roll you
know roles and stuff like he looks like
he's done some [ __ ] yeah i know after
analyze this i was like that
[ __ ] is so shady robin robert de
niro looks like the kind of guy you
bring your girlfriend home and then he
kisses her on the lips and you're like
really dad what the [ __ ]
i just realized you're wearing two
[ __ ] hats right now dude joe biden is
my [ __ ] president talking about old
guys he looks like
like how old is he he looks like he
kisses a girlfriend
he kisses him on the back of the neck
bro he plays like when you get when you
call him out for like why'd you kiss my
wife he's like what oh what are you
talking about he looks like guys like i
remember when your grandmother was just
small yeah she was in my shower she was
in the shower with me
wait what'd you say
[Music]
[Music]
you